I want to talk about the controversy
that's exploded over Ellen DeGeneres
being friends with george w bush and
defending her friendship with him and i
actually knew about this friendship for
a while between what seems in some way
sort of like an unlikely pair of people
who would be friends that a leftist
lesbian talk-show host and a neocon
republican former president and you know
i mean i think it's fine but part of
Ellen's commentary on this hasn't been
good and i want to talk through it with
you because as i've said before it's
really profitable to have a take on this
that is either one hundred percent on
one side or one hundred percent on the
other and the truth is that there
actually is some nuance here that i
think is relevant to discuss and I've
been very careful over the last two and
a half years of the trump presidency not
to inadvertently
rehabilitate george w bush's image so
when i say Trump is much worse than even
george w bush on this or on that i want
to couch it and make it clear that i am
not looking back at the george w bush
presidency through rose-colored glasses
or in any way minimizing the horrors of
the war criminality and all of the stuff
that george w bush did and the reason
that i think this is important is that
with time it's easy to forget how
disgustingly terrible george w bush's
presidency was and many of my viewers
were really young during that presidency
and may not even really remember it so
they're getting a lot of their
understanding of that presidency from
what i happen to offhandedly say that's
why i take it really seriously not to in
any way rehabilitate george w bush's
image when i compare him to donald trump
or to anything else so the other day
george w bush and ellen degeneres are
spotted together at a football game in
texas having a grand old time and some
people started to be mad about it how
dare ellen be friends with someone as
horrible as george w bush and the
controversy got big enough that ellen
responded to it on her show she did a
several minute segment on her show now
the right thing to do
this segment correctly would be to play
the video for you now and I planned to
do it but yesterday a bunch of people
got copyright strikes and their YouTube
accounts got completely destroyed by
Ellen's production company for using a
clip of the show and I don't want to do
that I think that'll be
counterproductive to the segment so find
the video online of her response it's
very easy she essentially said listen
I'm friends with lots of people I don't
agree with on politics we should be kind
to everyone when I say be kind to
everyone I mean everyone not just people
we agree with politically I'm friends
with people who wear fur and I don't
wear fur and I'm still friends with them
but when we say be kind to everyone I
mean be kind to everyone this is a
paraphrasing of her response but you can
pause this video if you're watching on
youtube find that video and then come
back I just want to avoid the problem of
the wrath of Ellen's production company
if I play the video now she almost has
it right in a sense but she goes too far
so if you want me to sit here and say
there's nothing wrong with what Ellen
said this is great bipartisan
friendships I'm not gonna say that if
you want me to condemn Ellen as a
terrible person for what she said and
saying it's completely wrong I'm also
not going to do that there is a good
message in there okay if people were
able to get along in general better
across party lines of across religious
lines cultural whatever society would be
much better off and Ellen is right I
mean we all have families and friends
and colleagues and you can't at every
opportunity that you meet someone with a
different opinion even an opinion you
find disgusting start attacking and
yelling even during a football game and
say I will not be around this person you
were not going to be invited anywhere
it's not a pragmatic way to carry about
your life that part of the message Ellen
is 110 percent spot on about but this is
a former president okay so for Ellen to
simply say we have disagreements just
like I know people who wear fur and I
don't but we're still friends
it suggests a sort of political amnesia
about the fact that george w bush is not
just your uncle who is against abortion
right and i think that that's the
problem I had with Ellen's response
george w bush is a war criminal with
blood on his hands whose decisions as
president led to the deaths of thousands
of American soldiers tens of thousands
or hundreds of thousands of Iraqi
civilians she's going in the direction
of almost suggesting that these are
differences like tastes and food or wine
but what we're talking about is one of
the biggest foreign policy blunders in
modern American history that led to
endless death sanctioning totally
unamerican torture by the US government
campaigning against LGBT rights by the
way Ellen of course being a lesbian
herself scaling up the war on drugs
really really bad and then the a lot of
hangers-on pop up and then they play the
role of the enlightened centrist and
this is just so stupid with really bad
takes here's one example there's a
Hawaii
congresswoman named Tulsi Gabbard who is
running for president actually who
tweeted quote Ellen's message of being
kind to all is so needed right now
enough with the divisive nough Sui can't
let politics tear us apart there are
things we will disagree on strongly and
things we agree on let's treat each
other each other with the respect
Aloha and work together for the people
so listen this is a fine message in
general but that doesn't mean you have
to apply it to the few people on the
planet who are actual war criminals and
whose decisions have actually led to the
deaths of tens of thousands or hundreds
of thousands now there will be people
who say but David you know the truth is
every president is responsible for
deaths through foreign policy right that
so does this mean you can't ever be
friends with any president no I'm not
even saying I have a problem with
Ellen's friendship with George W Bush
but the sort of flippant and glib glib
nature of not saying it's not just
disagreements it's his completely
boneheaded decisions we're not only
descri
against an entire class of people which
I am a member of and led to the deaths
of hundreds of thousands no it's just
listen some people wear fur and I don't
and it's just you know we're friends or
whatever so I want to be really clear
this is not about cancel Ellen I tweeted
about this a couple days ago and people
started writing back Wow David you're
canceled culture now you're trying to
get Ellen cancelled because she's not
being partisan you're part of the
problem no I like Ellen she can be
friends with George W Bush I don't have
a problem with a friendship per se even
I'm sure on a personal level he's a nice
guy he'll tell you about his paintings
that he does and whatever but the reason
that I'm okay with the friendship is
that ideally with friendships like these
we would be preventing people like
George W Bush from doing the horrible
things that he did when he got into
power in the first place in other words
we can't diminish the sick nature of
what he did to ik waiting it to choices
about food wine or wearing fur or not
and that's where Ellen loses me this is
a war criminal with the blood of
hundreds of thousands of people on his
hands who were optional casualties of
his administration there can be a limit
to unconditional kindness that doesn't
make us terrible people would we apply
the same thing to I mean I'm thinking
out loud I don't know the answer what do
we say listen
Osama bin Laden did terrible terrible
things but I'm about being kind to
everybody and we're gonna go hang out
and watch soccer in Pakistan or wherever
else I don't know maybe you do maybe you
don't what about a mass murderer
treating someone with respect versus
describing things as mere choice
disagreements is a problem so in the big
picture more discussion more friendship
socializing between people with
political differences is good but saying
that she and Bush merely have
differences of opinion is political
amnesia or it's indifference of the
worst kind that's the problem I have
with it